hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime opera and today i will be delving
into the crazy new developments in the
my batman academia manga
including deku's new secret weapon
and the possibility that deku has a
quirk that he still doesn't know about
or that he may know about but hasn't yet
been revealed to
us the readers the mha manga is so epic
right now and personally i am
loving it if you enjoy our pocono hero
videos and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and if you're new to anime out pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications before we get into it
a quick thank you to the sponsor of this
video
the unlimited fantasy mmorpg dragon raja
has some major breaking news a crossover
with evangelion
is coming a ton of evangelion related
events are arriving and since i love
evangelion i'm very excited
dragon raja is already known for having
absolutely stunning graphics and
gameplay
but the latest major updates that just
came to the game are
even crazier the new house system allows
you to build your own home
in dragon raja and the air and wedding
system
allow you to find romance in the game
and then cultivate on air to help you in
battle
and speaking of romance you absolutely
cannot ignore
these beautiful waifus you have the
choice of playing as either a guy or a
girl but i chose a girl because you
better believe that i'd rather look at a
stunning thick
waifu moving on screen the character
creation and customization options are
just
incredible and the grand and vivid open
world
is so much fun to explore download
dragon raja right now so you won't miss
the epic
evangelion crossover i mean you could
drive the evangelion test type 01 to
tour the game
and you can gather all your teammates to
resist an angel's attack how
awesome is that try it out right now
just click that link
in the description finally this video
will of course contain boku no hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned the latest
installment of the story starts off with
deku
straight up pulling a batman after
defeating muscular he ties him up
and takes him to the police he even uses
smokescreen to hand muscular over to the
police in a cool mysterious way that
doesn't reveal his
own identity and then he takes off again
scanning the streets for yet
more threats taking out a criminal and
then tying him up and leaving him for
the police is such a classic
batman thing to do it's literally what
he does in the opening of the batman the
animated series
and of course he does it on many other
occasions as well it's clear to me that
horikoshi
is a big fan of classic batman and
spider-man
and the new vigilante deku clearly has
elements of both of these iconic heroes
i also loved these characters growing up
so i am excited for the
ongoing evolution of deku dekku's
current behavior is definitely not
what we've come to expect from the
average law abiding pro hero
in the mha world deku did not finish his
pro hero schooling
he does not want fame or credit for
capturing criminals like muscular
and he really seems to be embracing the
vigilante approach
even shindo notices the profound change
that has taken place within deku since
the last time they met
shindo of course recognizes deku as the
kid he met
during the provisional hero license
exams but yet
at the same time deku seems like a
completely different
person in some ways he is totally
different
and not only in terms of his strength
like yes deku
is much stronger now and he has cool new
quirks
but deku has also changed as a person he
has matured
and evolved vaku then meets up with
alfred in a dark alley i mean
almight he meets up with all might in a
dark alley
almight is there on the scene in order
to advise deku and keep track of his
progress
almight asks whether dekku has sustained
any injuries in his fight with muscular
but deku confirms that he is uninjured i
mean that is crazy when you think about
it especially when we remember how deku
used to get
injured so severely in the earlier arcs
of the story
and we then learned that deku has a new
secret weapon
in his arsenal something we've gotten a
glimpse of in the most recent chapters
but didn't know much about
until now deku now has a special support
item that was delivered from outside
japan
right before the travel restrictions
were put into place
these travel restrictions must be
related to the widespread chaos and
multiple prison breaks that just took
place inside japan
presumably they don't want any of those
highly dangerous criminals to escape
abroad but still i have to say that
seeing deku talk about travel
restrictions
feels a bit too real right now anyway
the special support item around
deku's arms is the power stabilizing
mid gauntlet this is very similar to the
full gauntlet support item from the
first
mha movie the one that melissa shield
creates for deku
in order to help him stabilize one for
all's power
output almighty explains that this item
is a prototype that is supposed to
reinforce deku's entire arm and keep him
from getting hurt
but this is still just a prototype it is
still an experimental
item so that means that deku has to be
careful
he must not over exert himself before
the final showdown against shigaraki
because
as useful as this support item is it is
not
nearly strong enough to handle the power
of one for all at one hundred percent
that said though this is still an
amazing secret weapon
and it could absolutely change the game
for deku
that is especially true if a new and
improved version appears sometime in the
future
a version that can handle 100 of one for
all's power
while preventing injury to deku it seems
to me that
in the mha fandom we all spend a lot
more time talking about quirks and the
power of quirks than we do
about support items and modern
technology in general
and while quirks are certainly extremely
cool and it's a lot of fun to talk about
their powers and compare them to each
other
we can't forget that the world of mha is
a technologically advanced world
and so modern tech could end up playing
an important part
in the final showdown between deku and
shigaraki i don't think that modern
technology alone can defeat shigaraki
but a powerful combination of one for
all and modern technology could give
deku a huge boost in the upcoming
final battle against shigaraki i think
that we might see a lot more support
items in the future including upgraded
versions of this so called
mid gauntlet support item let me know
what you guys think about
this support item and do you think that
melissa herself
created it the chapter was very vague
about where
exactly the item came from we just know
that it came from overseas and it's
always hard to speculate how much the
events of a movie are going to affect
the actual plot
of the manga all might then receives a
call from hawks and best genius
who are currently in the process of
taking down a giant
villain this villain kind of looks like
the giant villain that mount lady took
down in the very first episode of the
anime and the very first
chapter of the manga although i'm not
sure if that's actually him
but regardless of whether this is that
same giant villain or a similar one
this is some pretty powerful symbolism
we have just entered
a new stage of the boku no hero manga
this is a new beginning the reason why
hawks called all might
is to see how deku was doing which
implies that the number two and three
pro heroes
are coordinating their efforts with all
might and deku
at the very least they are aware of what
all might and deck were up to
and they are interested in their
progress we then see a flashback that
explains how deku woke up from his coma
and how he ultimately decided to leave
the ua and become a vigilante
i'm actually really glad that we got to
see this flashback because we went from
deku still being in a coma
and everyone worrying about him to
suddenly him being fully awake and
sending letters to his friends telling
them that he is leaving the ua
that was a pretty crazy escalation all
at once so it's good to see how it all
actually came to that point
when deku finally woke up dr super mario
tells him that
even though he has done a lot of damage
to his body in the past
this time around the damage was not so
bad
most of the damage that deku sustained
during the battle of jakku was external
rather than
internal and beyond that it seems that
deku's internal structure has somehow
protected him from the inside out
dr mario believes that this might be a
side effect of deku's quirk
as his anatomy now appears to be
different
but this isn't a known effect of any of
the quirks that we've seen deku manifest
thus far so is this the effect
of a new quirk maybe the original quirk
of either the second
or third one for all user does
this new quirk potentially make deku
more resistant to damage or does it
allow him to recover quicker or maybe
it's some combination of those two
did this new quirk somehow change his
anatomy from the inside
out and is this a quirk that deku maybe
isn't even aware of yet
or is he aware of it now since he
presumably spoke to the second and third
user
of screen so maybe deku knows that he
has a new quirk but we the readers
still don't or maybe this new
development is just like a side effect
of the evolution of one for all itself
rather than a specific new quirk that
deku acquired there is a lot going on
here it is all very interesting so
definitely let me know what you guys
think
down in the comments below i'm sure
we're gonna get a lot more information
soon
but right now there's definitely a lot
to speculate about
dr mario then tells deku that he still
has to be careful and
take care of his body and after the
doctor leaves
almight finally reveals the truth about
one for all
to deku's mother inco when she learns
the truth
inko finally understands how one for all
works
but she also understands that deku is
now a major target for the most powerful
villains
in japan naturally this worries her
deeply but all might assures her that
everything will be done to protect
deku and that the ua is going to be the
safest place
for him however it is in that moment
that deku reveals to his mother and to
all might that he will
not return to ua deku knows that
shigaraki possesses quirks that are able
to locate
deku at any time so if shigaraki
ends up perfecting his new form sooner
rather than later
everyone at ua will be in grave danger
because of deku
deku absolutely refuses to let that
happen
so the major reason why he decided to
leave the ua is exactly what we thought
deku wanted to protect his friends and
he refused to put everyone he cared
about
in harm's way but beyond that deku
cannot just sit back and hide away
inside the ua he must get stronger as
soon as possible
and he must find and defeat shigaraki
and all for one before they have a
chance to attack
deku is determined to strike first
after a heartwarming moment between dekk
and his mother
inco seems to understand that in order
for him to be the kind of hero that he
always wanted to be
dekku has to do this deku promises to
come back
safe but for now he has to take the
fight
to the villains since allmight already
knows that he can't stop
deku from leaving he decides to support
deku and to work with him
and the top 3 pro heroes in order to
smoke the villains
out daku will serve as bait for
shigaraki
and the top 3 heroes will stick close to
deku
and so they will be ready to strike as
soon as all for one
and or shigaraki make their move on
deku so i was right when i said in my
previous videos that deku didn't leave
the ua
just to protect his friends that was
obviously a big part of it
but he also wanted to serve as bait in
order to get all for one and shigaraki
to reveal themselves
with deku seemingly fighting as a lone
wolf vigilante
all for one and the villains might get
cocky and attack deku before shigaraki
has perfected his new form
this would allow the heroes to take the
villains down before they become too
strong to stop
we then see the exact moment in which
gran torino gave his
cape to deku deku met with a severely
injured
gran torino before he left the hospital
thankfully gran torino is still alive
and in stable condition but he is
definitely not in good shape and he is
still
bedridden gran torino was glad to hear
that deku made contact with nana's
vestige and he says that he can't join
nana in the afterlife
at least not yet and then gran torino
says something to deku that i think is
very important and that i myself
talked about multiple times gran torino
tells deku not to be too stubborn
about saving shigaraki and redeeming him
some people cannot be redeemed and their
only salvation is death
here gran torino is warning deku about
how dangerous
it could be to try and save someone like
shigaraki if deku is not prepared to
kill shigaraki
he may end up paying for it with his
life after everything that he's done up
to this point
shigaraki may well be beyond redemption
and so trying to save him instead
of killing him could turn out to be
extremely dangerous
and not just for deku but for all of
japan if shigaraki were to somehow
emerge
victorious after the final showdown then
all of japan
will be doomed and of course that
includes all the people that deku loves
and cares about the final panel of the
chapter is an absolutely
awesome image of deku and all might
teaming up with the top 3
pro heroes to save japan from the
villains
so it seems that deku is not really a
lone wolf
after all he is fighting on his own as a
vigilante
and he seems to want the villains to
think that he is a lone wolf
but in reality he is working closely
with his mentor
almight and with the top three pro
heroes
this is definitely a great idea and i'm
really looking forward to seeing how
all of this plays out what did you guys
think about this chapter
and what do you think is going to happen
next personally i thought this chapter
was amazing
and jam-packed with important info and i
loved all of those allusions to batman
the chapter also almost made me feel bad
for muscular since the dude was out of
jail for like a whole five minutes
before getting wrecked by deku again and
getting re-arrested
but since muscular is such an evil
psychopath
i don't really feel bad for him since he
got what he deserved
if muscular was more intelligent and
strategic he could have easily avoided
captured the heroes are short on
manpower and they definitely would not
have caught him if he even tried to hide
it but he chose to engage
in very public mindless destruction so
he did this to himself
that said though a villain like all for
one will definitely not make the same
mistakes
as muscular so deck when the others need
to stay
on their toes this final showdown
between the heroes and the villains
is just getting started if you enjoyed
this boku no hero video and you want to
see more please leave that like to let
me know
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and if you are new to anime pro or
maybe you watch the channel but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
the only way to make sure that you won't
miss future boku no hero videos
is to subscribe hit that bell and then
select the option that says
all you can also hit me up on twitter
and
instagram at anime uproar
thanks again to the sponsor of this
video
check out dragon raja right now link in
the description
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you